hey everybody thanks for being with us
tonight i'm laura ingram this is the
ingram angle
fearing your own people that's the focus
of tonight's angle
[Music]
tell me what to do
[Music]
information wandering is really quite
ferocious it's when a hawkster takes
them lies and makes them sound
precocious by saying them in congress
for a mainstream mountainous
inflammation's origin seems slightly
less atrocious
nina jankowicz biden's new
disinformation czar over at homeland
security she's off-key and a really bad
julie andrews impersonation but it's
off-key in more ways than one
if we all didn't know that this was
really happening if you didn't just
witness that
we'd think this was all some kind of
orwellian spoof of what paranoid
conservatives think the establishment on
the left is planning
part angry feminist part frustrated
karaoke singer jankowitz is the last
person who should be trusted with
distinguishing between fact and fiction
she's a graduate of bryn mawr college
kind of a caricature of the modern left
university she worked at the liberal
wilson center a think tank globalist of
course it has a collection there of all
the worst ideas on foreign policy and as
an expert in eurasian affairs you would
think that ms jankowitz would have
authored articles maybe on the
importance of preserving free expression
in repressive regimes right
well not quite but she did publish this
gem
malign creativity how gender sex and
lies are weaponized against women online
oh can't wait to read that she even
worked as an advisor to the ukraine
foreign minister what
and most importantly for the current day
she is a hunter biden scandal denier
is this the same individual who said the
dossier was real and the hunter biden
laptop story was false is that the
individual who's now running the
disinformation governance board uh i'm
not familiar with those states been
reported widely
i'm not familiar with those
i'm not familiar with that well let me
enlighten you mr secretary
what the new dis info czar really said
about hunter biden's laptop was that
we should view it as a trump campaign
product
she obviously wants us to like i don't
know emulate a european style model of
heavy regulation of internet content
deemed harmful and dangerous
of course that just means content that
conflicts with whatever the left
believes about issues like climate
elections race and gender identity
the first amendment does not apply to
private platforms and facebook could
very easily decide that climate denial
or other you know harmful hate speech
and misinformation is not allowed on
their platform but they have decided
instead uh to allow this kind of free
speech fairy dust to reign over the
platform and i think that's where we
need to see regulation come in
you see how she had that laugh like
scuff free speech
now someone should give her a lesson in
basic administrative law because
if it were constitution as a delegation
of authority for the executive branch
to effectively outlaw certain types of
speech it doesn't like or doesn't agree
with
i kind of have a feeling that president
obama who actually is a harvard law
graduate
would have figured that out before this
biden bryn mawr crowd
but the real story here is a lot bigger
than ms tick tock meets america's got no
talent
the problem is the department of
homeland security itself
set up by president bush after 9 11 it's
a complete disaster i've been saying
this for probably 15 years
and now it's run by a man i wouldn't
hire to work security at a preschool
at any of the 42 illegal migrants on the
terrorist watch list or no-fly list
encountered on our southwest border been
released into the united states i do not
know the answer to your question
so look if you think that dhs exists to
protect the homeland you heard him
you're sorely mistaken it's entire
mission now this disinformation board is
to protect the elites from the homeland
in other words to subdue and surveil the
people who actually pay their salaries
now last time i checked
221 000 illegal immigrants crossed our
southern border they were encountered by
our border patrol this was in the month
of march alone that's a record i believe
congratulations mr secretary
no threat to the homeland there no
worries at all
well this only fuels our drug epidemic
you know it puts the cartels in charge
kills tens of thousands of americans
every year in fentanyl overdoses
but the only thing
that dhs is really worried about
is you
because they want to shut down
conservative speech ban anything
negative said about biden of the
democrats and punish you
if they think you get out of line
they call that by the way domestic
terrorism if you post something that
they don't like believe me that's what
they think
so i'm telling you someone like rand
paul should have the senate lawyers
write a letter to put the administration
on notice that republicans believe the
office of disinformation
has been set up to harass and intimidate
law-abiding americans who are simply
peacefully exercising their
constitutional rights
that they believe that it's being headed
by a rank ideologue and a gender
activist
and that the republicans also should
announce that if any american feels
threatened or in any way targeted by the
dhs
republicans will fight tooth and nail to
defend their rights
remember now
the government used 911 to justify the
creation
of dhs which just turns into this huge
surveillance
apparatus in the united states
the government then used covid to lock
us down mandate vaccines enclose schools
and even churches and now many of these
same people
are using january 6 in a similarly
nefarious way
as a way to limit freedom
attend a conservative event a trump
rally you better watch out even post
about it or maybe some criticism of the
biden administration maybe you're really
angry about the bite administration on
the internet
doing so could end you up on some type
of watch list
maybe you'll lose your job maybe you'll
even be put in jail
now the more
this goes on the more
obvious it is that these people do not
know how to govern america look at the
economic news this week
the more desperate democrats will become
to silence the opposition to punish
their domestic enemies
this is why for instance they're
freaking out about elon musk and twitter
but the department of homeland security
it was an idea whose time has long since
expired
should have been broken up many many
years ago they could have streamlined
intelligence without creating a new
super state style control of the
american people
it's too big it's too unwieldy it wastes
too much money and it's too ineffective
and by the way it's now actually
vindictive
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else